100万円企画1本目ぇぇぇぇぇ!!
100万円企画の1本目が決まりました
記念すべき第1本目は.......
あの〜、もう知っている方もいると思うんですけども
あの僕がですね、
バナナめっちゃくちゃ買って余ったときに
手伝ってくれた動物園の園長さんがいまして、
え〜、その方がですね
ちょっと今あるプロジェクトをやっておりまして、
緊急SOS 外来種収容巨大池建設プロジェクト
というやつが今、やっております
園長さんがね、池を造ろうとしております
爬虫類の動物園なんですけれども
ちょっと問題が今、起こってまして、
そもそも外来種ってなにか。
っていうお話です
外来種っていうと、
日本に元々、いない動物のことを
外来種といいます
普通のカブトムシは外来種じゃないんですけど
コーカサスオオカブトとか、
ヘラクレスオオカブトとか、
日本にいないカブトムシ、
あれはすでにもう外来種でございます
まあ、外来種の動物を飼う人、結構 いるんですよね
日本に住んでいないトカゲとか、
蛇とか亀とか飼う方、
結構、大勢いらっしゃってまして、
で、その動物たちが最近、
捨てられたり、破棄されたり、しています
それが今、ちょっと多すぎて、
社会問題になっていますと
で、園長さんの経営している
ｉＺｏｏ（イズー）っていう動物園なんですけれども
飼えなくなった、飼うことが....
色んな理由であるんですよ
無責任の理由じゃないときもある
家庭の事情とかね
なんか、病気になったり、いろいろあって、
飼えなくなってしまったりした
外来種のペットがいて、
動物園だと、その飼えなくなった外来種を
預かったり、育てたりしているみたいです
引き取りですね
で、もちろんこの外来種が日本に
パーって、例えば、
なんか、すごいめちゃくちゃ強い
外国の生き物が、こう日本にバーって放されると
そいつが日本の動物を、こう攻撃したり、
殺したりしちゃって、
生態系に影響を及ぼすかもしれない
っていう、結構でかい問題なんですよ
他の生き物が死んじゃうかもしれない
そこで園長さんが捨てられたり、
野に放たれるくらいだったら、
全て引き取りますということで、
外来種の動物をいろいろ、
引き取ったりしているんですけども、
それがもう、多すぎて、
キャパシティーオーバー
引き取る場所がないっていう
状況に今、なってしまっております
そこで、今、特に緊急を要しているのが、
亀。
亀の居場所がない
海外から来てくれた亀さんたちの
居場所がないので、
マジで多いらしいっすね
合計すると1000匹以上の亀がいるみたいです
そりゃ、1000匹もいたら、なかなかきついっすわ
そこで、園長さんは
どうすることもできない亀を
さらに収容するために
今、その巨大な池を造るプロジェクトが
進んでいます
あの、もちろん造るだけもそうなんですけど、
造ったあとの維持費とかね、
いろいろなことを含めると、
とてもじゃないんですけど、
すごい金額が必要なんですよ
そこで、え〜
100万円の最初の使い道は、
え〜、このプロジェクトに
100万円を投資させいただく
ということにしました
あの本当に、亀も救いたいし、
何より、僕、あの〜
園長さんにとてもお世話になっているんで
少しでも何か手伝いができないかな
そして、あわよくば、
池で遊べねぇかな
動画撮れねぇかな
とか思って、まあまあまあ
いろんな ことを含 めて、
亀のために、池のために、園長さんのために、
地球のためにっ!!!!!!
やってもいいのかなって
思いました
これ、100万円という金額が
すごいぴったりだったんですけど、
これ、プロジェクトでお金を集めれます
クラウドファンディングみたいな
みなさんもこれ、支援できまして、
申し込み金額が3000円、
5000円　10000円
3万円 5万円 10万円 30万円
100万円、このどれかの金額で支援が出来て、
100万円っていう支援の枠が
1人しかなくて
その1口を私、いただきまして、
100万円で僕が支援したやつには
その池の名前を決めれる
という特典がついております
ってことは、オレの池?!
まあ、僕の池っていうわけじゃないんですけども、
僕が、新しく出来る亀さんたちの池の名前を付けれる
という状態でございます
で、池まだ建設中なんですけども
どんな場所か、ちょっと
見にいってみましょう
GO !!!!!
奥ね、左、左、左
奥から2番目
今日はありがとうね
いや、とんでもないです
これが亀の池だよ
うわぁ、すげ、みんな浮いてらっしゃる....
多いですね
25メートル
なるほど、なるほど
で、その斜面の方まで
ここら辺まで
うん、その斜面の上くらいまでのここ
なるほど、なるほど
ここら辺も全部
元気いっぱいや〜
ここまで！
お〜、広いですね
なるほど
でも、近いっすね、すぐそこがもう
ｉＺｏｏ（イズー）なんで
パッと行ける距離
あの調節しているんだけども
出来るだけ早くね
暖かくなった頃には造りたいんだけども
もう許可まで取れているので
どうかな
4月5月には
出来ればいいかなと
なるほど、なるほど
おかげで、おかげさまで
いや〜、そんな僕は....
いや〜、その100万が大きいんだって
いや〜なんか本当に、園長さんには、あの〜
バナナの件とか、いろいろお世話になっているんで
何かしらでこうやってお手伝い出来て、
よかったです
ええ、本当に、もう
これからも第二、第三ね
造りたいなって思ってるんで
あ〜、もうぜひ、ぜひ！
よろしく
いや〜、こちらこそよろしくお願いします
ありがとう
また遊びに来ますね
また、よろしくお願いします
あの〜
思っているよりも何もなかったです
まだ、まだ開発途中ですから
あったかくなるまでに造りたいという
お話だったんで、
ちょっと夏ごろ、楽しみでございます
というわけで、100万円企画まだまだあるんですけど
いろんなの進めてますけど
まあ、バカなのもやるし、
こういう何かのために使ったりもするし、
俺のためにっ！使ったりもするし、
まあ、いろんな使い道を考えているので
ぜひ、お楽しみに！
いやほんと、楽しみっすね〜
なんか泳いで〜みたいな感じだったんで、
ちょっと池の名前は実はですね、
まだ決まってないんですけど
池が完成近づいたらまた、
お知らせしようと思います
というわけで、これで少しでも
亀さんたちが救えればいいなと思っております
で、この巨大池建設プロジェクトのご支援
え〜、3 月の１８日まで 行っております
この日本にいる他の野生の動物の命を救う
ことにもつながりますので、
ぜひ、みなさんのご支援をお待ちしております
めっちゃ宣伝みたいだな
ちょっとでもいいので、
みなさんのご協力をお待ちしております
というわけで、100万円企画、
どんどん進んでいってますので
お楽しみにっ！！！